encore un autre sujet qui n'a vraiment
rien à voir on a appris la mort hier de
karl lagerfeld
le célèbre couturier le l'homme qui a
ressuscité chanel lagerfeld dans notre
entre autres passions avec un chat une
chatte birmane qui s'appelle choupette
dont il parlait quasiment à chaque
interview en disant qu'il adorait elle a
sa propre petite fortune avec il déclaré
en 2015 c'est une héritière
on va fait de voir des images de
choupette en même temps que je vous
parle comme ça vous saurez qui s'est
alors et on s'est même posé la question
est-ce que cet animal pourrait hériter
du grand couturier alors en france à
nous paraît quelque chose d'aberrant
mais figurez vous qu'il ya des pays où
c'est possible par exemple aux états
unis et d'ailleurs
oprah winfrey qui est une une animatrice
de télévision extrêmement célèbre en
amérique a déjà dit que l aller les gués
30 millions de dollars à ses cinq chiens
un chat qui puisse hériter
on vit dans un monde de fous où après
tout pourquoi pas si c'est le souhait de
quelqu'un qui n'a pas d'enfant en plus
en qui fait ce qu'il veut de son argent
valérie toranian alors attendez on est
dans un monde de fous je ne sais pas
mais on est on est en train de parler de
la succession de l'est de l'héritière de
karl lagerfeld qui n'est pas n'importe
qui donc je pense que déjà il ya ça
lagerfeld c'est un monstre sacré c'est
une immense star non seulement de la
mode et du style mais des réseaux
sociaux et c'est un personnage
incroyable avec une démesure incroyable
comme on a peu connu
voilà dans les 50 dernières années il a
finalement la question de choupette et
ben ça donne aussi des proportions
totalement démesurée à la discussion
autour de sa disparition
et c'est son dernier clin d'oeil à mon
avis et c'est une façon aussi pour lui
de là où il est de s'amuser de nous voir
nous étriper autour de vous non je
coupais doit-elle être son héritière
après moi je suis assez je pense qu'il
est totalement dingue extravagant il
faut respecter une décision qui est
totalement dingue extravagantes et qui
lui correspond c'est ça va avec le
personnage
voilà il est allemand la loi allemande
le permet est ce que c'est ce que est ce
que la succession elle va être sur le
droit français et le droit allemand
jeunes ans
je ne sais pas elle va être sur le droit
français mais dans le monde sait que les
personnes morales et physiques comme
héritière à tout le monde donc je pense
que c'est ça il ya quelqu'un qui va être
chargé de s'occuper de choupette et
cette personne va comme a dit karl va
être très riche et elle aura pas de
souci à se faire pour ses fins de mois
schouppe est payant elle même son propre
compte grâce à tous ces revenus
publicitaires qui s'élèvent déjà je
pense à au moins cinq millions
donc voilà ça va faire quelqu'un de très
heureux avec chopin te jure je souhaite
personnellement personnages marginaux de
choupette jusqu'ici alors sur le puisque
géographie est ce que c est ce que c'est
choquant moralement ou c'est juste drôle
cette histoire moi je reprends à titre
personnel c'est vrai oui ça me choque
pas du tout ta place monsieur lagerfeld
en contradiction avec lui-même puisqu'il
avait dit quelque part je ne laisserait
aucun héritage je suis complètement
bidon donc c'est doublement des ventes
et d'une part il laisse un héritage et
d'autre part il n'est pas complètement
bidon moi je maintiens option un peu à
la mode donc c'est à peine s'il découvre
pas le personnage mais mais je trouve
formidable
là il fait une espèce de prestations
situationniste post mortem qui est
absolument extraordinaire
et en plus ils placent chacun d'eux
n'ont pas d'odeur
ça nous comprenons pas à l'idée du chat
ou l'animal de compagnie sont confrontés
l'idée d'héritage de manière qui est
philosophiquement assez passionnante à
mon avis mais je n'ai pas la développer
davantage le 1 4 kg ce que c'est
démagogique de dire que quand il ya
tellement de l'association qui oeuvre
pour ddd des actions d'intérêt général
on devrait plutôt donner son argent à
des oeuvres qu'à son chat les personnes
qui n'ont pas des rhétiques ont des
animaux de compagnie dont elles étaient
extrêmement proches c'est qu'elles
lèvent leur fortune par exemple la vespa
et la spa se charge des animaux on sait
pas quel montage a choisi car
l'adversaire est peut-être qu'il est sur
ce type de montage c'est à dire légué à
une association de protection des
animaux qui derrière s'occupera de de
son animal ou alors un tuteur mais avec
le cas sans doute il avait une relation
enfin effet il fait ce qui il avait le
droit dans le respect du droit et c'est
sans doute ce qu'il a fait il avait le
droit de le léguer sa fortune pour
qu'une partie de sa fortune
aïe au fait qu'on prenne soin de son
chat là on se met à juger alors on va
pas refaire il ya moins deux
protagonistes et choupette y en a pas
sur des plateaux télé sans doute pas
l'héritage de la famille de johnny
hallyday mais là vraiment si on va faire
du sensationnalisme pour dire aux
français car nagas aide avait des
millions de roubles il avait gagné 2
millions d'euros il avait accumulé une
fortune
est ce qu'ils pouvaient en faire ce
qu'ils voulaient 8 sans doute il n'a pas
non plus organiser une pyramide de
billets qui s'est mis qui s'est mis à
brûler il a dit oui de ma fortune
j'ai consacré des centaines de milliers
d'euros dans ma vie à mon chat je
continuerai à ont consacré après
magnétique après ma mort et on est dans
parlons plutôt de son héritage pop et
culturel très bien le sujet alors ce que
on a posé la question sur twitter en
êtes vous choqué par le fait que karl
lagerfeld lègue une partie de sa fortune
à son chat choupette bon moi je crois
dire que moi je jouis je suis choquée
mais je suis minoritaire sera la
première fois puisque 57% sur twitter
considère que non c'est pas choquant et
je vous donne deux points de vue nicole
qui dit je trouve scandaleux de léguer à
des animaux il a tellement de cause
qu'on peut soutenir est clos nous dit
pourquoi pas il n'a aucun héritier et
c'est son argent qu'il a gagnée par son
travail et on précise pour le répéter
que c'est pas à cet animal qui va
hériter mais peut-être on n'en sait rien
pour l'instant
des oeuvres qui pourrait s'occuper de
lui jean christophe buisson
mais moi je gagne comme vous sa dette
pour ça qu'on travaille dans le monde
journal flamion non non je suis je suis
choquée pas plus que quand michael
johnson a donné deux millions de dollars
à se rendre à son singe la bubble sale
époque sont champions et donc c'est la
même histoire en même temps elle résume
assez bien ce qui est karl lagerfel
c'est c'est bien dans son genre de faire
ça son genre qui est un genre
provocateur dandy bousculant tous les
codes y compris dans son travail bien
évidemment et en même temps qui
symbolise tellement l'égoïsme
l'arrogance
l'absence de effectivement de dons à des
aléas des êtres humains qui sont en
souffrance beaucoup plus que sa chatte
choupette donc moi ça m'a fliche qui
prennent ça en même temps je trouve que
ça lui correspond c'est bien c'est un
dieu c'était un dieu de la mode et en
même temps il avait des défauts qu'il
avait réussi à retourner de telle sorte
qu'on trouve ça rigolo et des qualités
mais c'est quand même aussi quelqu'un
enfin valérie quand est dirigée elle je
pense là beaucoup plus fréquentées que
moi mais l'impression qu'ils dégagent
aussi c'est cette forme et comme comme
beaucoup de grands écrivains comme
beaucoup de grands artistes et une forme
d'arrogance d'individualisme et de
l'absence de générosité qui est évident
si désolée il est un personnage de son
époque vous savez pourquoi
parce que cet individualisme qui veut
que je suis moi et non je me considère
dans cette société vous savez les droits
des animaux c'est peut-être le futur des
droits de l'homme on est dans une
société où les droits de l'homme ont
pris une importance énorme les droits
individuels énorme chaque communauté
on est tous en train de revendiquer les
droits un jour il y aura pourquoi pas et
guillaume va être extrêmement choquée
mais peut-être qu'on pourra en france
légué sa fortune à son chat peut-être
même qu'un jour on pourra faire des pacs
avec des animaux ce faire que le sens de
notre société post moderne
je dis quelque chose d'extrêmement
provoquant pour finir mais le sens de
notre société c'est tout le monde doit
avoir des droits et un jour on va nous
dire mais pourquoi pas les animaux aussi
en ce sens fait il était précurseur et
dans une provocation qui est assez de
son temps de redresser la sommer et
voilà et ses premiers on en reparlera
parce que c'est un sujet passionnant et
à mon avis effrayant mais ça n'est qu'un
point de vue merci beaucoup de nous
avoir suivis et rendez-vous demain à la
même heure sur le figaro live pour point
de vue merci
[Musique]